- Thanks to CuriosityStream
for keeping Legal Eagle in the air.
(thunder cracks)
He gently pulls the chair
away and grabs the doorknob.
He turns.
(doorknob rattles)
He pulls.
Oddly, there's slight resistance,
then he yanks the door
and Katko's life and
limbs are changed forever.
(door slams)
(man yells)
A man's house is his castle.
It's the place we feel safe.
It's the place we raise our children,
and it's the place we keep
our most precious belongings.
But to what lengths may we go to protect
our personal property and our home?
When is deadly force justified?
That's the question we must answer in
The Case of the Shotgun Booby Trap.
(dramatic music)
Submitted for adjudication.
Our story begins with a gift.
The year is 1957, the place
an isolated farm house
in Mahaska County, Iowa.
On this day, Edward and Bertha Briney
are thrilled to learn that
they're about to inherit
a fertile eight-acre farm
from Bertha's parents,
the shining gem amidst the
rolling golden wheat fields,
a farm house, a symbol
of the American pioneer.
The couple is elated,
they dream of passing on
their property to their
children and grandchildren.
Little do they know that
this quaint little home
in the heartland is about to
throw their lives into chaos.
Although they love the farm house,
Ed and Bertha do not live there.
Instead they reside in
another home outside of town.
They try their best to secure
the inherited property,
especially to protect the antiques
and heirlooms stored within.
Unfortunately, the
Brineys grow increasingly
unable to care for the farm house,
and it begins to deteriorate
faster than they can repair.
Both time and weather batter the house.
The harsh midwestern winters
strip the paint off the boards,
crack the windows like broken
teeth, and cave the roof in.
The home becomes dilapidated
and the Brineys are frustrated.
The gift starts to seem
less like a blessing
and more like a curse.
They have no idea how right they are.
Worse yet, the farm house
is isolated and vulnerable,
like a haunted house
beset by troubled ghosts.
There are no nearby neighbors
to protect the home,
and it becomes ripe for looting.
As the years pass,
Bertha's family heirlooms
start disappearing, stolen
by a persistent swarm
of criminals and thieves.
A series of trespassing and
house-breaking incidents
inflict more damage to the property,
and soon nearly everything
that Bertha treasured is gone,
stolen by looters that
seem to worm their way in
to the house like locusts, and
like locusts, strip it bare.
Angry and despondent, the
Brineys post keep out signs
and install locks, but all is in vain.
For a decade, Ed Briney
listens to his wife's pleas
as she begs him to do something.
Meanwhile, on the other side of town,
a couple of buddies are up to no good.
Meet one Marvin Katko, a
married gas station attendant
barely able to make ends meet.
He's been in and out of work for weeks
and is looking for some quick cash.
And meet Katko's soon-to-be
partner in crime,
Marvin McDonough, who has heard
about the Briney residence
and the easy money to be made there.
McDonough convinces Katko
that grabbing some antiques
could earn them a pretty penny,
and Katko is just
desperate enough to agree.
Before long, the two conspirators break in
and steal some antique bottles
and jars for preserves.
Their little heist proves fruitful.
Finally, something snaps in
the mind of Edward Briney.
Fed up with the looting
and wanton destruction,
Briney cleans and oils
his 20 gauge shotgun,
and he climbs the flight
of groaning stairs
for the second floor bedroom.
A desperate plan takes shape in his mind.
He ignores the uneasy feeling
in the pit of his stomach.
He is a man who has had enough.
Fury pulsing in his veins,
Briney enters the north bedroom.
Working by the light of
the late afternoon sun,
he secures the shotgun to
the foot of the iron bed wire
and runs another wire from the trigger
to the bedroom doorknob.
He crouches, adjusting the shotgun's aim,
leveling it straight at the
middle of the door frame
where it is sure to hit
the thief in the abdomen,
a death sentence, and then he
calls downstairs to Bertha.
When Bertha sees Ed's booby
trap, she has only one qualm.
She doesn't want the
would-be thief to get shot
in the stomach, so Bertha
convinces Ed to lower the gun
and to point it at the
bottom of the door instead.
Ed agrees and adjusts the shotgun.
He nails a piece of tin over the window
to prevent anyone from seeing the trap.
He loads the gun, cocks the
trigger, and closes the door.
Bertha shoves a chair
under the door's knob
as one last signal to thieves
that the bedroom isn't meant to be opened.
At last, the Brineys leave,
knowing the next person to open the door
is in for a horrifying shock.
Meanwhile, high off of their first haul,
Katko and McDonough decide to go back,
reasoning there must be more in the rooms
that they haven't opened yet.
So the two tiptoe back
onto the Brineys' land
under cover of darkness, but this time,
unbeknownst to them, they
face a bloody reckoning.
Katko and McDonough pry loose a board
from a back porch window.
They break and enter.
(glass shatters)
Once inside the house, Katko
goes straight to the bedrooms
while McDonough searches downstairs.
He enters the hallway, no one is home,
but he's careful to avoid excessive noise.
The old floor boards creak
with each heavy step.
Katko notices a chair under
the north bedroom door.
Strange, but no matter.
He gently pulls the chair
away and grabs the doorknob.
He turns, he pulls.
(doorknob rattles)
Oddly, there's slight resistance,
then he yanks the door,
(door creaks)
and Katko's life and
limbs are changed forever.
(gun fires)
(man yells)
The sound of the blast
is deafening, it's chaos.
Katko drops, one of his legs a bloody mess
of tissue and bone splinters,
the sickly sweet smell of
gunpowder fills the air,
adding to the pandemonium.
Katko screams in agony and
McDonough rushes to the bedroom.
He stares in dumbstruck horror,
Katko lies there writing.
McDonough lifts his friend on his shoulder
and half-carries him
down to the front yard.
From there, McDonough helps
as much as he can as Katko
crawls the seemingly endless
distance to the car where
the two finally rush through
the night to the hospital.
There, after doctors stop the bleeding,
they explain to Katko and his wife
that he needs three to four weeks of care
before the hospital can discharge him.
Katko has lost a substantial
amount of bone and tissue,
and his leg needs to be amputated,
but almost miraculously,
Katko barely avoids that horrible step.
Yet Katko's injury doesn't
prevent the law from swooping in.
After a 40-day stay in the hospital,
Katko faces the police who arrest him
on breaking and entering
and larceny charges.
Katko pays a fine of $50 and
serves a 60-day jail sentence
until he is paroled for good behavior.
Except for this, Katko's record is clean.
But this man's ordeal is far from over.
He suffers a full year in a cast
and another year in a special brace.
He wrestles with pain and
knows he will walk with a limp
for the rest of his life.
Katko knows he was committing a crime,
but the longer he sits, his
leg throbbing like torture,
the more he convinces himself
that he doesn't deserve this.
This isn't fair.
Something breaks in Katko's mind.
Like Briney before him, Katko
decides he wants justice.
(gun fires)
(tense music)
Katko served his time in jail
and paid his debt to society,
which brought the criminal
side of this case to a close.
But once out of jail,
Katko wanted compensation
for his gruesome shotgun injuries.
So like a true American, Katko filed suit.
That's right, the thief
sued the homeowner.
Katko claimed that his leg injury
resulted from unreasonable
force by the Brineys
to protect their personal
property by setting up
a spring gun, AKA a shotgun booby trap.
Needless to say, Ed and
Bertha Briney were furious.
The case went all the way up
to the Iowa Supreme Court.
The issue, whether setting up a spring gun
in an uninhabited house is considered
reasonable force for
protection of property.
In other words, was
Edward allowed to set up
a shotgun booby trap to
protect his house and home?
Remember, the house was unoccupied
at the time of the break-in.
So how far does the right
to self defense actually go?
We take you to the court house,
where the argument between
the lawyers for each side
is about to begin.
(typewriter clicks)
- [Judge] Good morning, this
court has had an opportunity
to review the record, the parties' briefs.
Are counselors ready
to begin oral argument?
- [Bruce] Yes, your Honor, Bruce Palmer
representing appellants
Mr. and Mrs. Briney.
- [Lawyer] Yes Justice, Geri Heslinga
for Mr. Katko, appellee.
- [Judge] All right then, let's proceed.
Mr. Palmer, what do you have to say?
- [Bruce] Thank you, and
may it please the court,
it is frankly a miscarriage of justice
that an admitted thief
would seek monetary damages
from the homeowners he tried to burgle.
My clients, Edward and Bertha
Briney, did everything right.
They followed the law,
setting up a mere deterrent
in their unoccupied home,
a home which was clearly
not meant for guests,
especially trespassing intruders
with intent to burglarize the home.
For 10 years, the Brineys
repeatedly installed locks
and posted many No Trespassing signs,
boarded up windows, and even
desperately sought assistance
from the Sheriff's department,
but none of these efforts
prevented continuous
break-ins and thefts to
the family's heirloom home.
Katko, the thief, had no right
to even set foot on the Brineys' land.
- [Geri] Your Honor, the
key to deciding this case
is the oldest legal question on the books.
Does the punishment fit the crime?
The obvious answer here is no.
The Constitution itself
prohibits cruel and unusual
punishment in criminal cases,
but it also makes sense in
a civil case like this one.
My client admitted he was
guilty of breaking and entering
and larceny in the nighttime,
but he was arrested.
He served his time and he
paid the required fine.
He paid his debt to
society and the Brineys.
Yes, the Brineys had a right
to protect their property,
but to the extent of
ruining a decent man's life
by blowing off one of his legs?
- [Bruce] All the Brineys
intended with the spring gun
in the bedroom was to scare intruders.
They had no desire or intention
to seriously maim or kill anyone.
Katko, while he tries to play the
"oops I made a little mistake"
card, actually carefully
planned the burglary to
steal the Brineys' valuables
and sell them for his own benefit.
He's a convict, a repeat offender,
and had no right to expect
warmth or safety in a vacant home
which he knew had been
repeatedly vandalized.
Imagine if he seriously cut himself
while breaking one of
the farm house windows.
That could be just as
dangerous as a shotgun,
but we would all agree that the Brineys
would not be liable for his injuries then.
This situation is exactly the same.
Katko's injuries resulted
from his own bad decisions.
- [Geri] Oh that's going too far.
My client not only suffered
the horrendous injury
at the time the shotgun
blew off much of his bone
and leg tissue, but almost
had his leg amputated,
needed crutches and a special brace
for almost two years and still suffers
substantial pain to this very day,
all because he attempted to
take a few antique bottles
to sell so he could keep himself
and his wife above water.
- [Judge] I appreciate
your arguments, counselors,
but the law is clear.
The relevant question for the court
is whether the actions of
the Brineys was reasonable.
Now Katko did not have
permission to enter the premises
and did not have permission to steal
the Brineys' belongings,
that much is clear.
However, as a society, we
don't want people setting up
shotgun booby traps or planting
landmines in their yards.
- [Geri] Your Honor, any
reasonable person knows
the terrible damage a shotgun
can do a point-blank range.
Indeed, the fact that the
Brineys lowered the aim
of the gun is an admission of that fact.
Thus, they obviously
intended to grievously harm
the next person to open that door.
In this case, it was poor Mr. Katko.
- [Judge] Mr. Palmer, do you think
the Brineys' trap was reasonable?
- [Bruce] I do, your Honor.
Was it reasonable for them to be upset
and want to prevent
further break-ins, yes.
Did they try less drastic
measures to accomplish their goal
prior to the spring gun, yes.
Did those measures stop the
stealing and vandalism, no.
Does it make sense for them to have taken
a more extreme measure, yes.
Your Honor, you called it a trap,
but that implies that
it was out in the wild
and that anyone walking in public
could have come within
the sights of the shotgun,
but the Brineys were careful
to only protect their own home
and place their deterrent
in their own bedroom.
- [Geri] Your Honor, the
flaw in the Brineys' argument
is clear, what if it had been someone else
that opened the door that night?
What if some young boys out for a walk
had decided to explore the dark home
as an adventure, as children sometimes do?
What if the boys, having no
plan to steal or vandalize,
had wandered through the home and then,
in one awful blast, a
child's life had been lost?
Clearly, the death of
an innocent young child
would not be reasonable just
to protect some property.
What else can we conclude?
The hidden gun trap was
intended to catch someone by
surprise and cause a devastating
personal injury or worse.
Imagine a person on trial
for attempted murder
and claiming that it couldn't be murder
because he only aimed for
someone's non-vital organs?
Preposterous, if my client
had not been accompanied
by his friend, he would
have bled to death.
The Brineys were out for
blood and they got it.
Now it's on their hands.
My client simply wants compensation
for the damage that they did to him.
- [Judge] Are we to
suggest that a homeowner
can never use deadly
force to protect his home?
Is that the precedent you want to set?
Mr. Palmer, under what
circumstances, if any,
is a spring gun a legally permitted device
for protection of personal property?
- [Bruce] Your Honor, the law is settled
that property owners may
use substantial force,
even spring guns and shotguns,
to protect their property
under certain circumstances,
including a home invasion,
especially at night.
Who's to say the Briney
family was not protecting
a dwelling where Mrs. Briney
may be spending time on her own?
She has a right to protect her
own life with deadly force,
so the only unreasonable matter here
is Katko's asking this
court to award him money
for an injury he sustained
by illegally entering a home
where the homeowner might have
been dwelling at the time.
- [Geri] Your Honor, opposing
counsel conveniently omits
that part of the
well-settled law that says
spring guns or other mechanical devices
installed to cause serious
bodily harm or death
may only be used if the
homeowner is present
in the dwelling while the trap is set.
We may not like the reason
Mr. Katko was there,
but his status as a
trespasser shouldn't justify
homeowners throughout the country
rigging firearms to
shoot anyone at any time.
- [Judge] Thank you, I
think I've heard enough.
Any closing remarks, Mr. Palmer?
- [Bruce] Thank you,
while it was mere property
my clients were protecting,
these were belongings in a home where
Mrs. Briney frequently spent time,
thus this case should be looked upon
as one in which the law
permits use of a spring gun.
It might be different if the belongings
were in a shack or a
barn, but they were not.
It was merely luck that the
Brineys were not present
at the time of the home invasion.
Yet Mr. Katko sees to punish
the Brineys for the good
fortune that they were not
home at the time he broke in.
- [Geri] Not withstanding
counsel's seemingly sound
argument, it is completely
unsupported by actual Iowa law.
Any reasonable person would have realized
that a 20 gauge shotgun precariously wired
to fire into a doorway,
any part of a doorway,
could cause serious bodily
harm or death to an entrant.
Thus the spring gun set up by the Brineys
was legally impermissible.
- [Judge] Thank you, counselors,
this matter is adjourned.
I will return soon with
the court's decision.
(typewriter clicks)
- Justice Moore wrote the decision
of the Iowa Supreme Court
in February of 1971,
and the precedent that it set is still
the law of the land in
Iowa and many states today.
Pause this video and let
me know in the comments
how you think this case came out.
(typewriter clicks)
(relaxed music)
The Iowa Supreme Court
held that the rule of law
to be applied was this: one may, in fact,
use reasonable force to
protect mere property,
but a homeowner may not
use a means of force
that will take human life or
inflict great bodily harm.
The fact that a trespasser may be acting
in violation of the law
doesn't change that rule,
and the only time the
setting of a spring gun
is justified is if a
trespasser is committing
a felony of violence or
one punishable by death,
or where a trespasser is
endangering human life by his act.
In other words, the
Brineys, the homeowners,
were in the wrong.
It was unlawful to set up
their spring gun booby trap,
and what happened to the Brineys?
Well hold on to your hats,
the jury's verdict for Katko
and against the Brineys
awarded Katko $20,000
for actual damages plus another
$10,000 in punitive damages.
The jury found that
the Brineys' booby trap
was so heinous that the
couple should not only
pay for the actual
damages but also $10,000
just to punish them.
So was it fair or unfair that
a trespasser attempting to
burglarize your house has
any protections at all?
It's difficult to disagree that human life
is more important than property,
no matter how sentimental the items.
But what do you think?
The case of the shotgun
booby trap is the first
in a new series on this channel.
I hope you liked it because it took about
10 times longer than my normal videos.
This is a huge experiment
because publishing on YouTube
is risky and in fact, this
video probably got demonetized,
which is why my creator
friends and I teamed up
to build our own platform
where creator's don't need
to worry about demonetization
or the dreaded algorithm.
It's called Nebula, and
we're thrilled to be
partnering with CuriosityStream.
Nebula is a place where creators can do
what they do best, create.
It's a place where we can
both house our content ad free
and also experiment
with new original series
that probably wouldn't work on YouTube.
In fact, if you liked this episode
of the case of the shotgun booby trap,
you can find an extended version on Nebula
that I can't show on YouTube.
And when I say Nebula is built
by creators for creators,
I really mean it.
Nebula features lots of YouTube's top
educational-ish creators
like Real Engineering,
Half As Interesting,
TierZoo, Knowing Better,
Real Life Lore, and tons of others,
and we get to collaborate in ways that
wouldn't work on YouTube, for example,
the Nebula exclusive series
called Working Titles
where every episode a
different creator breaks down
their favorite TV intro sequence.
Polyphonic did the Game of Thrones intro,
Patrick Willems did the
X-Men animated series,
and I'll be covering Law
& Order very, very soon.
(gavel bangs)
Seriously, we worked really hard on this
and we're all really proud of the result.
The project is self-funded,
we're not backed by investors,
and we've managed to make this ad free
and with no dreaded algorithm.
So what does this have to
do with CuriosityStream?
Well, they love educational
content and educational
creators, so they were the
perfect partner for Nebula.
We just recently worked out a deal where
if you sign up for
CuriosityStream with the link
in the description, not only will you get
one free month of CuriosityStream,
but you'll also get a Nebula
subscription for free.
And to be clear, that Nebula
subscription is not a trial.
It's free for as long as you're
a CuriosityStream member,
which means that for less than $20 a year,
not only do you get unlimited
access to CuriosityStream's
massive library of gorgeous,
high-budget documentaries,
but you'll also get to
enjoy the private playground
for YouTube's best educational creators
at no additional charge
for as long as you're
a CuriosityStream member,
and you'll be supporting
creators like me directly.
So you can go to the
link in the description
or you can go to
CuriosityStream.com/LegalEagle
and if you sign up using the link below,
not only will you be able
to access CuriosityStream's
amazing documentaries like 101 Events That
Made the 20th Century,
which includes my favorite
episode on Watergate for reasons
that are probably obvious,
but you'll also get a
subscription to Nebula for free
for as long as you're a member.
Seriously, it's less than 20 bucks,
and just click on the link.
So what do you think, did
the court get it right
or was this a travesty of justice?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and until next time,
I'll see you in court.